everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse and I was just finishing up with
my lunch that's why I was two minutes
late huh
today we're gonna upgrade next js2 the
latest version which is version 5 so
let's see it doesn't look like it's
gonna be too difficult but sometimes
when you upgrade things other things
break so maybe we'll work through some
of that who knows maybe we'll upgrade
everything will work and it'll be
awesome and then left to figure out
something else to do for the rest of the
show let me get my g feel ready for my
my caffeine hopefully I won't be yawning
too much as always G fuel you can
sponsor me if you want there's a music
on and let's get started
and yeah sorry I didn't stream yesterday
I just I had meetings at like awkward
times that didn't really allow me to
have enough time in between that I felt
like I could do a decent stream and then
I end up that my later meeting didn't
start till later than I thought but I
didn't know it was gonna start later
until too close to the meeting time so I
probably could have gotten a stream in
maybe next time I'll just try to fit one
in and you know maybe a short stream is
better than no stream I don't know let
me know what you all think if you'd
rather have like a half-hour long stream
on those days when I have a lot of
meetings instead of our normal you know
hour hour and a half stream let me give
you my screen here and I will point out
after we do the upgrade then I want to
talk a little bit about what's changed
in our routing so Nikki did some really
cool stuff with the router and I added
just some slight modifications so I'd
like to go over that a little bit later
on first things first let's check out
our well first thing let's let's start
our timer
here we are so after 25 minutes I'm
gonna go to the live chat answer any
questions you'll have so just hang in
there and please be patient and I will
get to your question all right so first
things first let's just check out our
package J so to see where we're coming
from and this could probably be a bit
bigger we don't really need a terminal
just now and we won't need this for a
little while so let's see what version
of next week are using swarm for point
two point three but what we want to do
is move on to five right so here is the
blog post announcing version five make
it a bit bigger spread it out a little
it's still pretty small on the screen
huh all right maybe that's it so there's
a lot of stuff in this post I'm not
gonna just scroll and read this out on
the stream but I will copy and paste the
link into the live chat so you can see
it and then I also put the link in the
description to this video so if you're
watching the recording later on just
check the description you can go right
to this blog post to read more there's
some new features build times are not
going to be faster they've they've set
up webpack now I'm not huge on web pack
set up in terms like I don't know all
the ins and outs of how to do it but it
seems as if now they're routing you know
front and back-end stuff through web
pack and now you can do things like do
all this different stuff with CSS so we
can do less set CSS CSS modules and they
even have these plugins now so I'm gonna
skip but you're welcome to read that on
your own if you like but now they have
these these plugins have CSS loaders for
you know sass or or less right so that
might be cool we could maybe instantly
have some sass
features in our in our next app so that
would I wouldn't like that we have run
sass with react before but it wasn't as
easy as just putting a plug in and
there's typescript support now I'd only
use typescript so we're not going to
really take advantage of that but if you
like typescript now that is now
available and let's see CSS
preprocessors you just talked about that
talked about module overloading which I
don't really know that much about it it
sounded cool though
optional source maps in production so
it's kind of cool there's some cool
thing there are some things that I'm
thinking like y'all probably use this
and there are other things there like
this is kind of cool not sure if I use
it or not but all in all it seems like a
pretty good pretty good update this
Zones thing seems interesting basically
running like multiple apps on one domain
and then just having it be like
obviously you can do subdomains and that
multiple apps but this is talking about
doing a subdirectory right you know so
mydomain.com slash settings would be a
completely different app living on a
completely different server than
mydomain.com so that i know that seems
pretty cool new Docs and now it's easier
to contribute to the docs which is cool
let's see what else here's the one about
the faster build time so they were able
to achieve 23.6% faster production build
times on their site on site what does it
site dot see uh I can't remember what
the site is yeah site site Co
better caching for imports so they
basically it from what I read it seems
like before
like on different builds your imports
would have like different numbers at the
end here so user would have to download
that again but now what would happen is
like if nothing changed in here when you
have another build these numbers
wouldn't change and so user wouldn't
have to redownload that maybe I'm
reading that wrong let me know if I'm if
I'm missing that but that's what it
seemed like what's going on here which
is which is really cool I could have a
you know definitely save your users some
some data especially if they're on
mobile that's a big deal but also you
could achieve some you have quicker load
times fragments all right so I don't
know if we'll switch things up to this
yet or not but it seems to me like we
don't need to use some of the things
that we were using in order to put in
like title tags and things like that
I believe maybe I'm wrong about this but
it seems like it's built in now to next
a different way to customize things like
that better errors which is great
because y'all know I get a lot of those
so now maybe it'll be easier alright
cool so that's my quick overview from
you know from me reading about this
earlier that that's what I remembered
so now let's let's update so I'm gonna
grab these and let's go back oops wrong
one I've been migrating more data over
so as always have more data so I'm gonna
do a yarn add and I'm gonna paste these
in so in case you can't read them I'm
gonna read them out quickly so we have
next at latest and then react at latest
and react on
at latest so let's hit enter and see
what happens whoa actually hold on a
second let's take this out of here let's
go to a different branch and then hit
enter that's weird let's get out of here
get checkout and then do the B flag
which I believe this will create the
branch and put me on that branch at the
same time which is always useful so you
don't accidentally start committing
things to the branch that you're on like
master not realizing that you didn't
move to the other branch which happens
it's happened to me before okay so this
is close branch next five awesome so now
we have a new branch it's called next
five and oops you decide yarn and there
we are now let's hit enter and see what
happens
cool does very quick nice all right
we'll verify here in our package.json
not that I don't trust that it worked
but let's see so we do we have next
five great it looks like react and react
Dom we're already at the latest versions
which is nice and anything else change I
don't think so this was these parts were
probably just Auto formatting or
something all right cool oh it looks
like the stream wasn't working no why is
the stream not working
alright so it's definitely not like the
CPU I'm not getting the fans running let
me try I'm gonna try to plug in the
ethernet cable I think I get faster
speeds for the ethernet I that at least
that's what I've been told I never
really tested it out but I unplugged it
because I can't migrate data over the
ethernet cord for whatever reason now I
can't find it
I lost my Ethernet I'm have to stand up
and cover the camera here so hold on
all right hopefully that will help
no I'm seeing drop down to nothing
all right now we're back up maybe it
just dropped down to nothing because it
was switching over hopefully we'll be
good all right okay cool so now let's
just see what's happening with this
now that we've upgraded let me find
where I have this running there so have
it up here
I've lost it there it is okay so here's
our app and I was on this page which
didn't work before so I'm not worried
about that but let's check the homepage
and let's get our console up so we can
see errors all right not bad not bad
that works now let's try some routes
all right faculty awesome that works let
me restart the server as well just to be
sure because with a with an update like
that I like to do like a manual restart
just to be sure let's refresh there we
are okay there's some errors here so a
free Actos server cool all right let me
go back to the home page interesting
all right so even our home page isn't
working so let's try this out one thing
we could do is go back to the
documentation first that might not be a
bad idea
so let's go here and see what we might
need to change
all right I'm going pretty quickly
through this so maybe missing something
but it didn't seem like there was
anything that said hey you need to
change this for this to work
okay let's see Harshit says try
reinstalling react dom yeah we could
reinstall that I mean we were trying to
update that at the same time and let's
see yeah I seen on the live chat so vibe
vibe have really wants me to answer a
question so just hold on I'm gonna do
questions in about ten minutes okay we
could
yeah let's do Rex could not resolve
react on server in node modules reactive
hallo hey here's Alicia do why not do
this the old RM RF node modules and then
just reinstall maybe maybe it'll work
and maybe it'll save a lot of time so
let's do that if you never use this
before sometimes it can fix all your
problems
you don't necessarily know what the
problem was but it does fix it so let's
try it
RM RF oh wait okay our [ __ ] says you
found he found the air okay alright node
modules your life has been spared from
now it's in the babble RC all right
let's check it out
I guess I could turn on where we have a
concern on Angra so you all can see the
errors as well I'm gonna pace this over
so you can click on the link I just
paste it in the live chat and then you
can have beautiful errors right on your
screen just like I do
alright well let's take a look then for
a second here at our babble or si
all right so it says try commenting out
the module resolvers stuff so we can
probably call them out coming out
everything here right
or actually just this right
we can't comment out in JSON so let me
just remove it then
all right
let me restart the server just to be
sure
cool all right that worked let's check
out some other pages nope
all right so this isn't working probably
because we're actually using some graph
QL stuff here but this is a different
error than we had before so I think this
error was caused by us removing all that
stuff about plugins so I'm going to put
this back in and see what Wow well you
see what we can do so evidently we need
this part for all of our our pages to
work except the home page so we can't
just take it out
it's so hard [ __ ] who's probably the one
that made this file in the first place
is saying remove the dollar sign so I
will try that
hey there we go it works let's try a
different page film study No
let's try another one
I'm not 100% sure that that route worked
anyway all right yeah it must be
shoot
why did that other page work I don't
know why it works for a minute oh all
right so I should say and restart yeah
so we didn't restart yeah let's let's
try that
I didn't restart because it looked like
it worked automatically so let's give it
a shot here
nope still there's
I'm gonna get out of this view so I can
zoom in a bit more ever so i'll ReactOS
okay i'm gonna remove hard should say
and remove the this little guy - sorry
about that hard [ __ ] I wasn't paying
attention in the live chat okay
no let's restart it
mmm
all right so let me check my timer all
right we got about two minutes left and
then I'll go back to the live chat and I
answer some questions but it's saying
the dependency was not found
I'm thinking it still might be worth it
to do our MRF and reload everything not
really a big deal for me I've got lots
of bandwidth
all right so I've just deleted all my
node modules please don't run RM RF if
you're not a hundred percent sure you
want everything deleted in that
particular folder because it will be
deleted forever you won't be able to get
it back but I can get all my node
modules back just by typing yarn so
that's what I'm gonna do and the timer
should be going off very soon so
let's see I don't think we're gonna get
anything else done 30 seconds oh cool it
finished I don't think it finished fast
enough let's restart this
dependency not found hmm all right well
that's it for that session so let me
take a 5-minute break I'm gonna go back
to the live chat if anybody has any
ideas for how we can fix this error that
we're getting please put it in the live
chat now I'll come back to it we'll give
it another shot after the five minutes
are up
also it's really hot in my office so I'm
going to take my sweater off see Gander
says anyone else going to watch the
SpaceX heavy Falcon launch as well maybe
I don't know what time it's on the
anybody know what time it's on for
Eastern Time
don't worry about if you don't know I
won't take me that long to look it up
but it might be cool to watch with my
kids later on as long as it's not too
late old so I says hello everyone hey
how's it going thanks for watching and I
miss everyone I don't know about you I
don't have anybody missed me but now
that I'm talking with you oh and
everything I did I miss I miss y'all I
tell you what it's really really easy
for me when I come in to just be lazy
and say like I'm not gonna stream today
you know I gotta you know get the
thumbnail ready for the video put the
info and schedule the stream you know
and it's not really that much all that
can be done in less than 20 minutes you
know probably less than 15 but sometimes
it's easy for me to be lazy and not
stream like yesterday probably could
have squeezed one in but it's like oh
well if it's not the right conditions
let's just not do it
but once I'm actually here with you all
I really love it so anyway just wanted
to tell you how much I appreciate you
she AB ass please give me a complete
guideline to be a developer I'm not sure
I can give you a complete guideline and
in the time that we have right now but I
would say as a rough kind of outline
learn HTML and CSS probably learn things
in this order if you want to be a
front-end developer or even a full-stack
developer learn things and do it in this
order HTML CSS basics right you don't
need to get too in-depth then go into
JavaScript it's probably not a bad idea
to learn a little bit of jQuery it's it
can get your confidence up and
realistically you'll probably be able to
find a lot of jobs that require jQuery
so depending on what your circumstances
are it might be beneficial to you
otherwise just stick with JavaScript and
start building things if you want to be
full stack and moving to back-end then
learn node that'll be the easiest jump
for you to make from javis like
client-side JavaScript to get into the
backend and then you'll probably want to
learn a little bit more about api's and
databases and things if you want to just
stick with front-end though
stick with your JavaScript and then if
you want to check out something like
angular or react or view to help help
you out you'll go with that if you want
to be able to follow on with these
streams definitely check out react and
it probably couldn't hurt to check out
some sort of UI framework like material
UI fusing react or materialized CSS or
bootstrap or foundation or something
like that depending on how much you like
the design CSS side of things if you
really like doing it yourself then maybe
you don't want to use a framework but in
any case it is it's good to at least be
knowledgeable of those frameworks and
how things are done in them because
those are like common design patterns
the users are familiar with so even if
you don't want to use them I still think
it's it's a good idea to be familiar
with them so anyway that's like kind of
my just outline of what to learn if you
want to ask me know maybe I'll do a
video of more
in-depth stuff if anyone's interested in
that let me know would you like me to do
a video or a series of videos outlining
a good plan for what to learn and when
to become a developer if you like it
just leave some in the live chat leave
something in the comments of the video
or something like that
and then if enough of you are interested
then I'll kind of make more of an effort
to to do that also I says maybe in short
streams you could do question and answer
actually that's not a bad idea if I'm
doing a short one maybe I'll just say
like hey this is just a cute I stream
yeah yeah cuz it is kind of difficult to
get much work done and just like a half
an hour but question answer would be
pretty easy that's a pretty good idea
thanks Brooke says about the routing I'm
sure that code can be rewritten about
half the lines while being clearer and
more performant Oh Nicki don't I I know
I already told you in the the comments
to that PR but I think it was genius I
mean it was really good is the only
thing I had to change and I we can talk
more about it is routes that weren't
included in that that object where we're
actually bringing up an error so I just
had to put a change it up just a little
bit to make sure that those routes
actually did end up going to the
universal route but other than that it
was was great all right let's get back
to the code and let me write down where
I'm leaving off
Yeah right and if anybody's interested
in doing some refactoring with that you
know hey you know feel free to take a
shot at it you know as long as the
functionality remains the same and it's
still readable that would be awesome
let's see here we go okay I'm gonna
check the bottom of the live chat
quickly to see if anyone had any more
ideas about Harsin it looks like Harshit
made a pull request
I didn't even merge this it's already
made a pull request let's check it out
all right let's go to github and once I
get in here I will make it bigger there
we are and best feather okay cool so
let's check out the file first so we can
see so harsh it has put in roots source
no way that's awesome so that was the
only thing to change all right hard [ __ ]
do you want to get credit for this pull
request I will merge it in or do you
want me to just copy and paste this let
me know I'm more than happy to give you
credit and actually merge this pull
request see
our she says just copy and paste okay
that's cool
urgent says I made this as you might
have forgot the carrots hole file why do
I need to do the whole file it just
changed one thing
hold on a second modules over alias
okay so right above alias
I know you thought you thought I was
gonna forget all the stuff that I change
right
but that control-z is my friend all
right hey well at least we got a fresh
new node modules folder right so
restarting
hmm
it's not working for me yes that will
check I'm gonna pull over harsh it's
code on my other screen so I can compare
exactly what it was
okay so it is exactly the same I mean
the formatting is a little different but
oh yeah still same air
same thing okay hmm
michael says is react Apollo even in
node modules I I would imagine it would
be let's check it out don't need it at
blank file there what's this this is
some cool stuff I'll have to share that
with you soon I thought I already had it
open I guess not
there's my package.json there we are
that's a good thought though Michael
it's worth checking it out
Apollo yep yep react Apollo here
modules can't resolve react on server in
we react Apollo
we could dive into node module and here
see what's going on
here's the thing I don't get I like
really we didn't change react Dom we
didn't change react Apollo that's what
we're getting the air from react on
server and react Apollo that kind of
bothers me
I would get another arrow down here I
know it's hard to see
yeah this was sure fine it's never
modules tab who lives have Jess
okay arch says try removing what is that
called the caret sign and the dollar
sign after this all right let's give
that a shot my Babel save dad
no same thing all right so let's change
that back I don't like to you know so
this is what that that file is looking
for react om server so react Apollo
somewhere it's searching for react on
server
alright it looks like this dream cut out
but now it's back alright
sorry about the stream I just I don't
know what's going on with it today I
haven't changed anything about OBS
settings I don't know
okay so harsh is saying remove the cache
from the node modules which I did not do
before so let's do RM RF node modules
slash cache and the next one
why is it not found of course it's there
maybe it's just something with the
copying
area
that's weird so Microsoft Outlook is
giving me a notification right now for a
meeting that was cancelled it even tells
me cancelled and it's not I was telling
me I have 11 minutes to get this meeting
with that seems like it's something it
should not be doing
see all right
so say that wasn't it as well
yeah same error and you know
raluchi she was the ADA
okay so saying
that's odd
all right so yes I don't you'll see that
when I mouse over doesn't that look like
an odd path
yes
all right so in react Dom or server
digest is just this we also have
I mean the only thing I can see is that
react Apollo is once a an older version
of react Dom
I mean again that just it doesn't make
that much sense because let's sit this
no I Donnie Eric for working with Saddam
down here it has a different version
hmm
all right let me let me go with the left
has to go saying Michael is saying why
not just reinstall react Dom server like
the message says I mean well I mean
technically we just reinstalled
everything right when we removed all our
node modules
see
it looks like someone else had a similar
problem with a previous version of next
so there's an issue a closed issue on
next J s repo trying to scroll down to
see what what happened with that
yes
I kind of thought we'd have errors I
just thought I would have a little bit
easier time getting through it alright
so I'm going to paste in the to live
chat the issue that I'm seeing right now
in case anyone else is interested and
then I'll pull it over onto the screen
so you can see you can see what I'm
looking at right now so I was a little
skeptical because this issue was from
June of 2017 so I figured like an issue
that old has probably already been taken
care of but it looks like it maybe
wasn't so even after the issue was
closed we have the issue still happening
oh this is still happening in beta
version of next
mm-hmm in this case if the app is built
everything works but in development it
doesn't work
all right so there is a fix
Oh Gander has to go hey again or thanks
for joining us I'll see you later
John Hanson says I saw some stuff on the
web similar issue NPM babble plug-in
module was over and create an alias
module resolver for reacts Apollo in
Belvoir see
mm-hmm I'm just not finding really new
issues I'd rather have something newer
but I mean I guess potentially if this
issue just happened again with this
release then there's there's not gonna
be a lot oh wow
almost to the end of another 25-minute
session here really glad I did this in a
separate branch
I think it's a really really long shot
that this will works and so much has
changed since this version of next but I
think it's worth a shot let's see
ying-ying ye so I'm not sure how to
pronounce your name so why ing j IE
please let me know how to pronounce it
I'd love to pronounce it correctly for
you but anyway it says there's no super
chat here now I haven't done the super
chat at all is there an advantage to
doing the super chat if so let me know
alright let me make this file really
quickly just to see if it works and then
I'll go back and go through everything
the live chat so it's saying do this and
where that's it's closed up these node
modules modules close this
ooh
if you
you know what this isn't gonna work this
person's issue also I had to do with
change effectuation of different sized
shoes
and it also had to do with type scripts
hmm
oh okay so it seems like super with
super chat you can make so you can get
donations that's pretty cool I'm not
gonna start doing it for free code camp
stream unless that's what Quincy wants
so right now I'm not gonna use it but
I'll definitely keep that in mind that's
that's pretty interesting all right
her shirt says he's got it so I'm gonna
wait for more on that from Harshit and
in the meantime I'm gonna go up to latch
at where I left off and I'm gonna answer
some questions
Nietzsche says Oh wowthat's today
bleeding-edge stuff right here yeah it
just came out I actually thank Harshad
for hearts just sent me a message was it
a message no I think it was an issue I
should open an issue on this repo saying
that next five came out so I saw that
check it out this morning if the
holidays maybe this would be cool for a
stream
let's see
on Hill says hi hey how's it going son
bassist Jesse the hacker in which
company do you work right now I work for
a small University called Franciscan
University of stupid about five of us
there are so many frameworks of
JavaScript like react angular of UJS
ember meteor etc we have to learn all of
them to become a good developer oh no
way no way you don't have to learn all
of them you could be a good developer no
none of them and just use JavaScript or
you could just learn one of them and be
really good in fact I would think if you
knew all of them you probably wouldn't
be really good at any of them usually
take specialization to become really
good so yeah don't worry about that you
don't I mean it'd be good to know a
little bit about each one just so that
you can accurately assess whether which
one would be best for a particular
project that you you're about to work on
but don't you certainly don't have to
really learn every one of them and it
says hey hey how's it going
glad you could make it for the latch at
Gander has said the RM RF node modules
doesn't fix as much as it used to
since NPM self-clean since version 5 all
right good to know good to know maybe I
won't be so quick to try it next time
then
again just said the SpaceX launch is
actually going on like right now liftoff
is at 2:20 Eastern Time
alright cool well I'm gonna try to end
the stream before then so y'all can
watch the launch if you want to I'm high
school Creole said I thought you just
had a hangover from watching the
Superbowl not actually I didn't even
watch the Super Bowl this year
I just watched like a kids movie with
with my kids and went to sleep I'm
actually a Pittsburgh Steelers fan and
they weren't in it and just wasn't that
into it this year James says Jessie
beard is looking awesome this beard is
looking awesome bro I appreciate it
thank you it is getting a little long
and you can't thankfully you can't tell
on the camera at least I can't tell from
seeing OBS but it's starting to get a
little gray I got some gray hairs right
here on the chin my wife laughs when she
sees that so I don't know we'll see how
it looks once the stars turned gray
maybe I'll look better
who knows I'll look more distinguished
right with gray
divya says it's completely off-topic but
do people use react with django apps i
have never heard of anyone usually react
with django but i mean that that it
certainly people could be doing it i
just don't know about it i don't know
much at all about django I've never used
it so i'm i probably can't give you a
good answer has anyone else heard of
anything like that allen word says
thumbs up for the video on getting
started and motivation on day 21 of 100
days of code and life got in the way and
had to take a week off now it's hard to
get started again thanks for everything
you rock I really appreciate you telling
me that and I'm glad that you liked the
video hopefully it's helping you out
maybe I'll have to I'll have to make
another one here because I've added in
some things into my daily routine that
have really helped since I made that
video and I think it could be helpful
for some people so maybe I have to make
a part 2 or something along those lines
yeah but I appreciate you telling me
that when I get feedback like that then
I mean it's good because I know what
what kind of content is helpful for
people Aleksey says hey hey how's it
going world's us why didn't you just
leave next yes version 4 we certainly
could have left next version 4 version 5
did have some improvements that I liked
so it was easier to integrate sass the
build speed was faster so I don't know
did we have to probably not but it I
mean while we're still developing it
it's a heck of a lot easier I think now
before everything's are all built out to
update like this that way if we do have
problems there's just less code to look
through to try to find the problem
I mean if we really can't figure this
out we can always just flip back to the
master branch and come back and try
again at some another time but I still
have a lot of data in my grade so I
don't really need to work on this repo
you know right away
so we'll see I it's worth giving it a
little bit more time all right it just
automatically popped me back down to the
bottom of the live chat and I see that
Harshit is typing in all caps which
means that he's got something for me oh
you know I had to leave so it was too
late here I gotta go to sleep all right
well good night Anna thanks for joining
us let's see see this got it we're gonna
see this oh I should says do the work
around in there
so hard [ __ ] were you talking about that
workaround that I was just going to make
so like this in the issues okay oh I
should that's a good point arch it says
remember to back up the WordPress
install because it could set me back
that is very very good point
I'll shoot I know I did that because
this was supposed to be typescript
now this type shift even gonna work for
me in here will automatically work with
next five or you have to set that up I
guess we'll find out really soon
we had a flash of content yeah remove
that show all right remove the any
okay
the suppose I could take the typescript
off of here now
all right so we still have some stuff
going on suspected digit because of you
syntax error number all right we got
some syntax errors stuff going on here
but we it worked let's try some other
pages now I'm not happy yet because I'm
I'm like waiting to see if something
else breaks I'm not convinced yet all
right now I'm pretty convinced all right
all right cool now I can smile and be
happy
cool
all right so this was pretty cool
hopefully this will be helpful for
anybody who's trying to upgrade now I
guess not everybody's gonna have the
same configuration that we had so it
probably won't happen for a lot of
people I don't know but here was the
deal right so we upgraded and we ended
up having to add next dot config dot J s
file ok just down here in our main
folder right and we had to put module
exports and looks this deletes some
aliases so this is what we had to put in
there alright now this will be in the
repo soon once I push this so you can
you know copy and paste this use this
file if you need to for what you're
doing and hopefully it'll help you cool
Oh Nikki's Nikki's computer crashed
basically because of the same error and
so Nikki missed the fix so this is the
fix this right here so I'll I'll push
this let's push this now do you think
we're safe enough now to merge this into
master
hmm
what are you what would we call a commit
that's just updating packages
there are dependencies
michael says don't merge it yet alright
well I'll just keep it on this branch
for now
all right so we're just gonna say this
is build I mean really the the the piece
of this that we could most immediately
benefit from anyway is that we'll have
faster build time so that kind of makes
sense
oops I should saying it's a chore so we
should say put it under chore all right
all right thanks up [ __ ]
are there any breaking changes there
were we fixed them yes it does affect
any an open issue what issue is that
let's see I don't remember what issue of
us have to look it up
seventy-five
uh you know we have to pass all the
tests
did we pass yay all right
all right cool so we do have a branch in
our github repo now that is for next
five so if you want to see any of the
stuff that we just did today
check out that next five branch we're
not gonna merge it yet Michael I think
as has the right idea here is not to
merge it yet double check make sure
things work give it a little bit more
time to test then we can merge it when
we're when we're sure all right cool let
me try to get through the rest of the
questions in the live chat and no I said
I'd try to be done before the rocket
launch sorry about that
totally understand if you were watching
this and watch the launch I'll still go
through and answer the questions though
all right let's see you know what I
don't think I marked where I left off I
just have to read some of it
Niq alright I see now where Nicky said
that the lab saw the blue screen of
death out of the blue on this last hub
nick says this looks hard I learned PHP
well PHP looks hard to me so that's yes
it just depends on what you're more used
to working with Oh harsh it says the
Instagram uses Django with react well
that's that's a really big example thank
you for bringing that up
Lexi says can you run react alongside
with express in next Jas
yeah that's we have let me show you my
server the server JS file here yeah so
we've got Express running we have next
running obviously react so it's all it's
all running together nick says where can
I learn about cyber security for free
thanks for your apply I don't know for
sure I've not taken cyber security curse
courses well I think that but I did do
some of the course on Udacity so I
believe Udacity has some courses or at
least one course on cyber security that
you can take for free I imagine there
are a lot of courses on on udemy that
probably aren't free so I would check
out the one for Udacity from what I
remember of it it was actually taught by
some people who are really kind of like
big names in the field of cyber security
they have literally written you know the
authoritative books on cybersecurity so
check that out first
I'd say that's probably a good place to
start
also says while you're doing your
project are you concerned about security
website like CSRF attacks equal Jacksons
or that is not a possibility a front-end
developer or at least Fernandez should
know these this stuff yeah so we
definitely try to keep that stuff in
mind for just purely front-end stuff
it's
there are different things to be
concerned about but you know potentially
by using so this is where I see the big
advantage of using established like
pre-made things as as opposed to
creating everything on our own you build
things from scratch they just haven't
been tested but if we're using things
that that have been tested like for
instance wordpress order managing
content through wordpress very well none
frequently updated mostly updates a lot
of the updates have security updates in
them as well so we don't have to purse
like act like know all the different
threats out there as long as we have a
reliable you know maintainer so the
people who maintain wordpress are pretty
on top of things one of the biggest
threats for WordPress is plugins that
are out of date so in terms of plugins
I'm very careful about what I install
and what I use and if it's a plug-in
that doesn't seem like it will be
updated or it's no longer maintained I
make sure I take a look at the code you
know as best as I can with my limited
knowledge of PHP and and try to really
understand what's happening so yeah so I
guess I say I'm worried about it that's
one of the reasons why I think upgrading
plugins and things is important
especially if you become aware that
there's a security issue I do have some
people in the computer science
department and that are interested in
doing some penetration testing so
hopefully we can get that set up and
working and you know so people that are
more knowledgeable about security than I
am can really kind of check things out
and make recommendations
okay I'm gonna have to go pretty quick
and wrap this up so I just got a message
that the head of the department needs to
meet with me because and it may have to
do with this website so definitely don't
want to keep her waiting
I know says this project is getting good
that is nice see they keep pushing okay
michael says they keep pushing to launch
back now it's a 90 minutes okay well at
least we didn't miss it okay I got to
the end of the live chat sorry I'm have
to just cut it off right there so maybe
join us for another chat if you have
some more questions thank you so much
for all the help and working through
these issues thankfully we you know we
got it all working but I really
appreciate all the help and I should be
back tomorrow until then have a great
day